[موسيقى]
يوم 7 ديسمبر الحالي الرئيس الصيني شيجن
بنك زرق اكبر مصدر عالمي للبترول هو
المملكه العربيه السعوديه زياره وصفت
بالتاريخيه خاصه وان شي زي ما بنقول كده
ما بيطلعش من بيتهم يعني من ساعه ما وباء
كوفيت نايتين بدا وتشيل ما عملش اي رحله
خارجيه غير لاسيا الوسطى في سبتمبر اللي
فات فسيرته للرياض هي رحلته الرئاسيه
الثانيه في سنتين تقريبا والاولى للسعوديه
خلال قرابه سبع سنين في الزياره التاريخيه
دي تم توقيع مجموعه من اتفاقيات مهمه جدا
بين الطرفين ركزت على مجاله الطاقه لكن
الاهم من الاتفاقيات دي هو السؤال الكبير
اللي طرحته شبكه سي ان ان وهو هل السعوديه
هتدي الصين الجائزه الكبرى في عالم الطاقه
وهتبيع جزء من نفسها باليوان الصيني بدل
الدولار الامريكي الحقيقه الزياره ما
قدمتش الاجابه واضحه على السؤال لكن ورقه
او جزء منه وعملات غير الدولار كانت على
طاوله الحكومه السعوديه من كذا سنه بسبب
العلاقات المتقلبه واشنطن في السنين دي
اخر التقلبات دي مثلا حصلت يوم خمسه
اكتوبر اللي فات ده على طول لما تكتل اوبك
بلس اللي بتاخذ السعوديه بالتعاون مع
روسيا قرر خفض انتاج النفط بمعدل 2 مليون
برميل يوميه وده قرار اغضب الامريكيين جدا
زي ما حضراتكم وخلاهم يهددوا السعوديه مره
بمنع صادرات الاسلحه وقطع غيارها ومره
ثانيه بتفعيل قانون نوبل اللي بيسمح
بمحاكمه السعوديه ودول اوبك بتهمه ممارسه
الاحتقار في اسواق الطاقه وغيرها متهديدات
طبعا التهديدات الامريكيه دي مش جديده
ومعظمها غالبا بينزل على ما فيش زي ما
الاسابيع اللي فاتت وضحت لكن اللي يهمنا
اكتر هنا هو ردود فعل السعوديين على
التهديدات دي اهم ردود دي هو اللي ذكرته
صحيفه الامريكيه يوم 24 اكتوبر بعد 20 يوم
تقريبا من قرار اوبك بلس نقلا عن مسؤولين
سعوديين في محادثات خاصه من المملكه ممكن
تفكر تبيع الحصه اللي بتحتفظ بها من سندات
الخ الامريكيه لو اقر الكونجرس اي تشريع
مناهض لاوبيك او السعوديه كل ده واكثر
يخلينا نسال شويه اسئله مهمه جدا وخطيره
زي مثلا اللي يخلي المملكه تستثمر فلوسها
في الديون الامريكيه وايه اللي يخلي
امريكا تتداين وتبيع ديونها اصلا لدول
الاجنبيه وازاي بدات حدوته استثمار
السعوديه في سندات الخزانه وايه هي بالضبط
سندات الخزانه دي وحجمها قد ايه وايه اللي
بتعمل لكوا السعوديه منها وايه علاقه
السندات بنظام المترو دولار وهل ممكن
السعوديه تبيعها هيستها من الديون
الامريكيه والسيد ده ممكن ياثر على امريكا
والسعوديه نفسها دي عينه من الاسئله
المثيره اللي هنجاوب عليها وعلى اخرها
النهارده بس قبل ده بافكركم ان الحد
اللحظه اللي باصور فيها الحلقه تقريبا ما
زال نصف عدد اللي بيتفرجوا على المخ
والاقتصادي مشتركين في القناه اشتراك
حضراتكم مهم جدا هو اللي بيساعدنا نطور من
شغلنا ومن المحتوى المخ في الاقتصادي
دائما ونحافظ على مستوى فما تنسوش تشتركوا
بافكركم برده ان كل حلقات ان اللي فاتت
مترجمه للغه الانجليزيه فما تنسوش
تشتركوها مع اصحابكم الاجانب وتعرفوهم على
القناه يلا بينا نشوف حكايه السعوديه
وامريكا والبترولر انا اشرف ابراهيم
المخلق الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
اول خطوه لازم تعملها لو هتاسس مشروع او
حتى عاوز تطور مشروعك الحالي وتشوف هل انت
ماشي صح ولا في حاجه غلط انك تعمل دراسه
جدوى محترمه للمشروع ودي لازم تعملها شركه
متخصصه وده شغلها شركه المهمه
الاستراتيجيه اللي طالعه الحلقه دي هي
شركه متخصصه في دراسات الجدول اقتصاديه
للمشاريع الاستثماريه مسجله ومقراها في
السعوديه وكمان شاطرين جدا في التاهيل
لشهادات الايزو من خلال استشاريين متخصصين
زاويه خبره عمليه طويله في دراسه وتخطيط
عدد من المشاريع الصناعيه الطبيه
والصناعيه وتطبيقات الموبايل اسفل الفيديو
في تعليقات يوتيوب وفيسبوك هتلاقي رابط
لماصه بتاعتهم تقدر تعدم منه الحقيقه ان
تلوح السعوديه بيبيع النفط بعملات غير
الدولار وتهديدها تبيع سنه الامريكيه اللي
بتعملها هم مسالتين مرتبطين ببعض اكثر من
ما نتصور والقصتين تقريبا بداوا سنه 2016
وقت الرئاسه
حول الرياضه بتمرير قانون يسمح لضحايا 11
سبتمبر بمقضادات الحكومه السعوديه بزعم
تورط مسئولين سعوديين في دعم منافذه
الهجمات تمرير القانون ده معناه ان
المحاكم الامريكيه تقدر تحجز على الاصول
السعوديه الموجوده على الاراده الامريكيه
واللي قيمتها وقتها كانت تقدر ب 750 مليار
دولار علشان تدفع تعويضات لاسر الضحايا
ساعتها السعوديين قالوا للامريكان بوضوح
احنا مش هنستناكم لما تعملوا كده وهنبيع
احنا الاصول بتاعتنا دي بما فيها سندات
الخزانه وبداوا في تسريب اخبار حوالين
مفاوضات لبيع النفط بعملات غير الدولار
وعلى راسها ليوان الصيني طبعا التهديد
الامريكي نزل على ما فيش اوباما زي ما كان
متوقع استخدم حق الفيتو لتعطيله القنوات
بالضبط زي ما فيهاش على عده محاولات سابقه
لتمرير قانون انه ده ومن الواضح ان ده
هيكون مصير المحاوله الاخيره لتمرير
القنوات الوقت محتاجين نفهم بسرعه كده ايه
هي سندات الخزانه دي هي ببساطه اوراق
جنسيه
الحكومات لتمويل انفاقها بفوائد مختلفه
بتزيد مع زياده اجل استرداد السندات
وبتشتريها سنه دي ومؤسسات محليه واجنبيه
وبتكون مضمونه من الحكومه نفسها وبما اننا
بنتكلم هنا عن امريكا اكبر قوه اقتصاديه
في العالم
فالسندات الامريكيه بيكون عليها اقبال
كبير جدا لان مخاطرها قليله او شبه معدوم
احد فيهم هيقول لي طب دي السندات 10 قل
لنا برده يعني ايه البترول ده قبل ما تشرح
اللي بيحصل بصوا يا جماعه وركزوا معايا
علشان الحكايه دي مهمه جدا جد البيترولر
هو مصطلح بيطلق على الدولارات اللي
بتدفعها الدول مقابل الحصول على البترول
او نفطر الخام وتسمع كده لان غلبيه
كمياتها النفطه اللي بتتباع في الاسواق
العالميه باستثناءات لتكات تذكر بتتباع
بالدولار الامريكي حتى لو ما كانتش
الاولاد المتحده طرف في الصفقات دي اي شكل
طبعا ده مش مستغرب لان الدولار هو عمله
الاحتياطات العالميه والطبيعي ان معظم
المعاملات بين الدول الاجنبيه بيه وده من
ساعه توقيع اتفاقيه بروتون وودز سنه 1944
اللي تم فيها ربط الدولار بالذهب على اساس
35 دولار لكل اقيم ذهب ووعدت امريكا من
خلالها بانها تشتري اي كميه دولارات من اي
دوله وفي اي وقت لو الدوله دي عاوزه ده
وتديها ذهب بالسعر ده وبالتالي كان معنى
كده ان امريكا لازم تحتفظ بكميات ذهب
تعادل قيمه اي كميه دولارات بتخرجها في
الوقت ده دخلت امريكا في سلسله ازامتك
اقتصاديه خليتها ما تلتزمش بالتعهد ده
وطبعت كميات كبيره جدا من الدولار فوق
كميه الذهب اللي عندها والموضوع ده خلى
دول كثير تزعل ومنها دول حليفه زي فرنسا
اللي راحت للامريكيين قالت لهم خذوا
الدولاراتكم ورجعوا لنا الذهب بتاعنا
فردوا الامريكان وقالوا ما معناهاش وما
يلزمناش وخرج الرئيس الامريكي ريتشارد
نيكسون على الهواء في 13 اغسطس سنه 1971
واعلن الغاء قابليه تحويل الدولار لذهب
لاي دوله لفتره مؤقته والفتره المؤقته دي
مكمله معنا لحد الوقت المهم ان هو من ساعه
طلعت نيكسون البهيه دي اتلغى ربط الدولار
والعملات بتذهب للابد وباقي الضامن الرئيس
لقوه الدولار هو الثقه في التزام الحكومه
الامريكيه وقوه موقفها المال قرارات
نيكسون او صدمه نيكسون زي ما العلم سماها
تسببت في انهيار كارثه في قيمه الدولار
مقابل الدرهم من 35$ لكل رقيه ل 135 دولار
للاوقيه سنه 1973 ودي نفس سنه حرب اكتوبر
ضد الكائن المحتل ووقتها واشنطن ارتكبت
غلطه كبيره بتعمل احتلال بالسلاح
والدولارات وده استفز معظم الدول العربيه
المنتجه للنفط في منظمه اوبك وعلى راسها
السعوديه فالدول العربيه دي قررت تتدخل
وتسند مصر وصوريه واخذت قرار بخافض انتاج
النفط بنسبه 25% وده تسبب في زياده سعر
برميل البترول من ثلاثه ل 17 دولار وقتها
والقرار ده ضرب الاقتصاد الامريكي في مقتل
وتسبب في زياده معدلات التضخم وطباطؤ في
القطاع الصناعي وانهيار في اسواق الاسود
وبشكل مجمل دخل قرار الدول العربيه ده
لاقتصاد الامريكي كله في ركود غير مسبوق
من ساعه الحرب العالميه الثانيه بتعمل ايه
امريكا علشان تطلع من الورطه دي قال له
لازم نرجع نربط الدولار بسلعه حيويه
واستراتيجيه ثاني في السوق العالمي بدل
الذهب ولو بشكل دائم علشان كده في يوليو
سنه 1974 بعد نيكسون وزير الخزانه
ويليامسام وناقبه لجده في مهمه غير قابله
للفشل كان هدفها اقناع السعوديين بيبيع
النفط لامريكا والعالم كله بالدولار
الامريكي وفي المقابل الامريكان تا-
اجراءات فوريه لتثبيت قيمه الدولار وتزويد
المملكه بكل اللي بتطلبه لحمايه امنها
الصفقه دي عالميه بصفقه المترو دولار لكن
الامريكيين بيسموها الامن مقابله النفط
علشان يدوا ايحاء ومبرد لان صفقات الاسلحه
وتدخلاتهم العسكريه وغيرها في المنطقه
كانت منحه منهم للسعوديه والدول العربيه
المنتجه للنفط الامريكان بيقولوا كمان ان
السعوديه وتوع الاوبك ما كانش عندهم بديل
عن بيع نفطهم بالدولار للحفاظ على اربحهم
بعمله مستقر وده كلام صحيح لكنه كعاده
كلام الامريكيين نصف الحقيقه بس الحقيقه
الكامله بقى بتقول ان الامريكيين كانوا
محتاجين صفقه البترول دولار دي اكثر من
السعوديه بكثير وهما الحفي وراءها لانها
حرفيا هي اللي انقذت الدولار من الانهيار
طب ليه لانه بخلاف ان الصفقه خلق الطلب
كبير على الدولار عالميا وده خلى الدولار
يستعيد جزء كبير من توازنه بعد صدمه
نيكسون فهي كمان ساعه امريكا على التغلب
على عجزها التجاري وتمويل الفجوه الكبيره
في الانفاق الحكومي عن طريق البند الثاني
من الصفقه اللي هو هيبقى ايوه بالضبط كده
زي ما خمامته تعهد السعوديه بشراء الديون
الامريكيه او سندات الخزانه وبالتالي ضخ
فوائد الدولارات الناتجه عن بيع النفط في
الاقتصاد الامريكي من جديد يعني هي امريكا
كان عندها ديون وكمان كانت بتجري تشوف حد
يشتريها ويمول انفقها الاجابه ايوه لان
طبيعه الاقتصاد الامريكي نفسه فرض الدعم
بصوا يا جماعه وركزوا معايا شويه في الحته
دي علشان مهم امريكا بعد صدمه نيكسون وبعد
ما الدولار تحول لعمله احتياط عالميه بدون
غطاء من الذهب وقعت في مشكله بيسميها
الاقتصاديين معدله تريفن او مفرق الترفن
بالنسبه للعالم الاقتصاد البلجيكي
الامريكي روبرت بيقول ايه يا عم تريفن ده
بقى بيقول ان اي دوله عظمى بتتحول لعملتها
لعمله احتياط عالمي لتسقط في حاله من
التضارب الحاتمي بين اهدافها الماليه
الداخليه واهدافها العالميه او الدوليه
معناها ايه الكلام ده برده الدولار علشان
يكون عمله احتياطي لازم امريكا تكون قادره
على توفيره لكل الدول والجهات اللي بتطلبه
وضخه بانتظام في الاقتصاد عالمي ومنع حدوث
اي نقص فيه وده معناه دولارات كثيره خارجه
من البلد في المقابل احنا اتعلمنا مع بعض
ان اي اقتصاد علشان ينمو ويخلق قيمه
ووظائف محتاج يجذب التدفقات النقديه ويمنع
هجره الاموال للتعارض ده بين الضغط
والمانع بيخلي الدوله اللي عملتها عمله
احتياط عالمي بتتشد بين قوتين عكس بعض قوه
الفلوس اللي لازم تخرجها للسوء العالمي
وقوه الفلوس اللي لازم توفرها للانفاق
الداخلي نتائج خناقه القوتين دول بتخلي
دائما في عجز مزمن في الحساب الجاري البلد
دي يعني اللي خارج اكثر من اللي داخل
وبتعمل عجز في الموازنه يعني كميه الفلوس
المتوفره جوه البلد اقل من اللازم لتغطيه
الانفاق الحكومه باختصار يعني النفقات
بتبقى اكثر من الارادات طب بتعمل ايه
امريكا علشان تسد العجز ده هتعمل زي اي
دوله في العالم عندها عكس هتروح تستلف طب
اقوى دوله في العالم تستلف منين في وقت
العالم كله بيكح تراب هتستلف من الدول
القليله اللي عندها دولارات كثير مش
محتاجاها وفي فتره السبعينات بقى ما كانش
في دوله بينطبق عليها ده غير السعوديه
وشويه من دول اوبك الغنيه بالنفط وعلشان
كده صفقه البترول الشهيره تضمنت استثمار
فوائد الدولارات الناتجه عن بيع النفط في
سندات الخزانه الامريكيه لتمويل انفاق
الحكومه الامريكيه زي ما قلنا من شويه
يمكن ده يفسر سر اختيار ويليام سيمون وزير
الخزانه اللي كان نيكسون جابه وقتها من
عمل السابع كمدير لمكتب سندات الخزانه في
بنك الاستثمار الشهير برازرز وعينه في
منصبه الحكومه ببساطه لانه زي ما وصفته
وكاله البلومبيرغ كان اكثر شخص فاهم جاذبي
الديون الحكومه الامريكيه وعارف ازاي يقنع
السعوديين بفكره ان سندات الخزانه
الامريكيه هي اكثر مكان امن لحفظ قيمه
اموال النفط بتاعتهم انت كلمتني عن امريكا
والبترولر وسنادات الخزانه وما كلمتناش عن
السعوديه ايه اللي خلا المملكه تقبل
بالصفقه دي هل موضوع كان حبا في عيون
الامريكيين مثلا ولا علشان السعوديين
كانوا مضاعفه وبيسمعوا كلام امريكا
الاجابه لدى ولا ده لا الامريكان كانوا
اقوياء بزياده ولا السعوديين كانوا ضعافا
بالعكس الضربه بتاعه حظر النفط العربي وقت
حرب اكتوبر كانت لسه معلمه على جسم امريكا
في وقتها الاجابه ببساطه يا جماعه ان
الدولار كان فعلا هو العمله الاكثر
موثوقيه لتسعيره النفط وتقريبا ما كانش له
بديل وده يعني بتبعيه من سندات الخزانه
الامريكيه وقتها هي واحده من اكثر الطرق
اماما لتخزين فوايد ارباح النفط لان
امريكا كانت ولا تسال الدوله الاكثر قدره
على سداد ديونها في عالم ما بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه ولحد اللحظه دي بجانب ده
الامريكان تعاهده وبيستثمار جزء من
الدولارات دي مره ثانيه في مشاريع تنويه
داخل السعوديه سنه 1979 واخيرا بقى كان
الاتفاق بان جزء من الفلوس دي هيروح كروب
من امريكا لبنوك الدول الناميه في افريقيا
وامريكا اللاتينيه اللي هتستخدمها في شراء
منتجات صناعيه منتجه في امريكا واليابان
واوروبا وده هيحفز القطاع الصناعي في
الدول دي وبالتالي تشتري نفط اكتر من
السعوديه وبك وهكذا دوره ارباح متكرره
ومستمره طبعا جزء قروض الدول الناميه ده
كان نظري بس غير اللي حصل على الارض
الواقع وفقا كلام ديفرسبيرو في كتابه
الياده الخفيه للهيمنه الامريكيه ففي سنه
1977 يعني بعد ثلاث سنين بس من صفقه
البترول السعوديه رقم حوالي 20% من جميع
سندات الخزانه الامريكيه المملوكه لجهاد
خارجيه والحقيقه ان الرقم ده كان مجرد
تقدير وده لانه وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه و
بموجب التفاهم على المملكه حافظه على سريه
سياسه السعوديين من سندات الخزانه لحد سنه
2016 لما قررت واشنطن الكشف عن الارقام
الدقيقه اللي بتملكها كل دوله من الدول
المصد النفط بما فيها المملكه وفقا
لبيانات 2016 في السعوديه كانت بتمتلك
سندات خزانه امريكيه بقيمه 117 مليار
دولار ومن وقتها ولحد النهارده الرقم ده
شهد تغيرات كثير بشكل شهر تقريبا هو حاليا
مستقر عند
121.1 مليار دولار وفقا لبيانات شهر
اكتوبر اللي فات 2022 وده بيحط السعوديه
في المركز رقم 16 في قائمه اكبر الملاكين
الاجانب للسندات الامريكيه طبعا 121 مليار
دولار دول مش رقم قليل ابدا لكنه برده مش
رقم مرعب لو حطيناه في سياق الديون
الامريكيه كلها لان اجمال الدين القومي
الامريكي في شهر اكتوبر اللي فات ده كان
31.2 تريليون دولار الدين هو ده بينقسم
لفئتين كبار ديون للوكاله الحكوميه الديون
للجهات العامه او جمهور الوكاله الحكوميه
دي هي الفلوس اللي استلفتها وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه من جهات حكوميه ثانيه جوه
امريكا نفس دي حجمها 6.8 تريليون دولار بس
حد حيسالني ايه اللي يخلي الوكالات
الحكوميه الامريكيه الثانيه تستلف من
وزاره الخزانه هاقول لك ان في وكالات
حكوميه امريكيه زي صندوق الضمان الاجتماعي
وصندوق التقاعد العسكري وغيرها عندهم
فوائد ماليه مش محتاجاها بشكل فوري فبدل
ما تروح تحوش الفلوس دي تحت المرتبه بتروح
ببساطه تسلفها للحكومه وزاره الخزانه
وتاخد عليها فوائد النوع الثاني بقى من
الديون الامريكيه والاكبر هو الدين العام
وقيمته بتقترب من 25 تريليون دولار وده
متوزع بين البنوك والمستثمرين الامريكيين
والاحتياط الفيدرالي وحكومات الولايات
والحكومات المحليه خصناديق الاستثمار
المشترك بصناديق الادخار والاهم من كل دول
الحكومات الاجنبيه اللي بتستثمر في سندات
الخزانه زي السعوديه قيمه الديون اللي
بيملكهها الاجانب حاليا حوالي 7.2 مليون
دولار منهم 121 مليار دولار بتعمل لكم
يعني حوالي 1.6% بس من الديون الاجنبيه
الامريكيه مملوكه للسعوديه طب مين بقى
بيملك النسب الاكبر من الدهون الامريكيه
دي في العالم بحسب بيانات اكتوبر 2022 ولا
هي احدث بيانات متاحه في المركز الاول
تيجي اليابان بحوالي تريليون و 78 مليار
دولار بعدها الصين ب 910 مليار دولار ثم
بريطانيا ب 638.5 مليار دولار بعدها
بلجيكا بحواله 327 مليار دولار ثم جزر
كامل بحوالي 297 مليار دولار وبعدها
لوكسمبار حوالي 296 مليار ثم سويسرا
بحوالي 263 مليار وبعدها
239 مليار ثم البرازيل بحوالي 225 مليار
ثم فرنسا ال 218 مليار تقريبا وتايوان 216
ثم كندا 215 مليار ثم الهند
13 مليار ثم هونغ كونغ 186 مليار ثم
سنغافوره ب177 مليار تقريبا وبعدهم تيجي
السعوديه ب 121 مليار دولار زي ما قلنا
وداي خلينا نطرح سؤال الحلقه الاساسي
والاهم اللي سالنا في اولها يا ترى
السعوديه ممكن تقرر تضرب كرسي في الكلوب
وتعاقب الامريكان وتقول لهم مش هنشتري
ديونكم ثاني او هتبيع ديونكم اللي عندنا
وناخذ فلوسنا وايه اللي ممكن يحصل لو
السعوديين عملوا كده السؤال ده مش احنا
لوحدنا اللي بنساله في المخبر الاقتصادي
لكن مراكز صناعه القرار الامريكيه تسالوا
مع كل ازمه بتحصل مش بس مع السعوديه ولكن
مع اي دوله من الدول المالكه للسندات
الامريكيه وتحديدا الصين اللي ملكيتها
للديونه الامريكيه اكبر بكثير من السعوديه
علشان كده في مصطلح مخصوص اعرفكم عليه
دلوقت الامريكان بيوصفه به عمليه البيع
الانتقام الديون الامريكيه بيسموها تسليح
الديون او تسليح السمادات ومعنى المصطلح
ده ان دوله تقيله زي الصين او البرازيل او
فرنسا او السعوديه تقرر تنتقم من امريكا
لاي سبب عن طريق ضحيه ذاتها من الديون
الامريكيه بشكل مفاجئ وده هيضطر واشنطن
لرفع سعر الفائده على السندات علشان
تستقبل مشترين جداد لشراء الكميات الكبيره
المطروح واللي بالتبعيه هيؤدي لهبوط في
قيمه الدولار وانخفاض في قيمه الاصول
المقاومه الدولار داخل امريكا وخارجها
طبعا حجم التاثيرات السلبيه دي هيتوقف على
كميه السندات المباعه ومدى قدره الوكالات
الحكوميه الامريكيه وخاصه مجلس الاحتياطات
الفيدرالي على امتصاصها من الاسواق وفي
حاله السعوديه تحديدا لو بصينا للارقام
هنلاقي ان نسبه ما تملكه السعوديه من
الدين الامريكي حاليا قليله جدا مقارنه
بالوضع في السبعينات وده من الناحيه
الفنيه يخلي امريكا عدل انها تحتوي اثار
اي عمليه بيع للديون السعوديه دي واضرار
قليله نسبي الحاجه الثانيه اللي بتخلي
الامريكان مطمنين شويه من الناحيه دي ان
الخسائر الناجمه عن بيع الديون دي هتمسى
السعوديه نفسها للاسف وده لان المملكه
بتحتفظ بمعظم احتياطاتها النقديه السياديه
بالدولار وعندها اصول واستثمارات مقاومه
بالدولار جوه وبره امريكا وده معناه
بالتبعيه ان اي انخفاض في قيمه الدولار
هيضر ثروه المملكه نفسها وهيقلل قيمتها
النقطه الاهم هي انه لو المملكه اتخذت
قرار بالفعل بالتخلص من السندات والاصول
الدولاريه بشكل تدريجي فده يعني انها
محتاجه تنقل اصولها لعمله ثانيه او على
الاقل تنويع الاصول دي بنسلم العملات ودي
خطوه فيها مخاطر كثيره جدا في ظل كون
الدولار هو العمله الاكثر استقرارا عالميا
والاهم ده انها بتتطلب حدوث التحول الجذري
اللي ممكن يشقلب الاقتصاد العالمي بدون
مبالغه وهي من السعوديه ودول اوبيك يبداوا
يبيع طبعا النفط بعملات ثانيه غير الدولار
طبعا التحول ده صعب جدا ومعقد وهيبقى
انقلاب كامل على صفقه المترو دولار
تاريخيا لكن لو بصينا للعالم مواجهه نظر
السعوديه في الوقت الحالي هنكتشف ان
الموضوع مش مستحيل ابدا وانه رغم صعوبه
حصوله خلال السنين القليله الجايه فوارد
جدا ان ده يتغير على المدى الطويل وده له
عده اسباب بدايه كده العلاقه بتاعته النفط
والامن الامريكي دي بالنسبه للسعوديين بقت
قديمه وتجاوزها الزمن حاليا امريكا هي
اكبر منتج للنفط عالميا وده يعني بشكل ظني
ان صناعه النفط الصخر الامريكي هي منافس
رئيس للنفذ السعودي فمش منطقي ابدا ان
سياسه السعوديه تختم مصالح الامريكيين على
حساب مصالحها غير كده امريكا ما بقتش من
فتره لا باس بها اكبر مشتري لانها في
الصعود يعني المشترين الاكبر حاليا هم دول
شرق اسيا زي الصين اللي بتستورد لوحدها
25% من صادرات النفط السعودي
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه والهند وحتى في
مساله التحالفات والامن والامور بدات
تتغير صحيح امريكا لا تزال اكبر منتج
ومصدر للاسلحه للعالم وللسعوديه بشكل خاص
لكن النظام الدولي بتاع اكثر مرونه بكثير
مقارنه بفتره السبعينات والحرب البارده
وبقى بيسمح للدول بتنويع تحالفاتها وعدم
اختيار جانب واحد بس فرساله السعوديه الى
الامريكيين ممكن نختصرها في التالي من
الاخر كده احنا هنشتغل مع الكل وهتبيع
وهنوع موردين من الاسلحه وهنسود انتاج
النفط او نخفضه بالشكل اللي يهدم مصالحها
وممكن كمان نبدا نبيع النفط بعملات ثانيه
زي الوان الصيني ويبقى فيها عقود بتروان
زي ما في بترولر ده لو به اكثر من مسؤول
سعودي اكثر من مره في الفتره الاخيره طيب
يا اشرف ادينا سيتون السعوديه ممكن تبيع
سنادات الخزانه الامريكيه واصولها في
امريكا دلوقت ولا لا الاجابه حاليا هي لا
صحيحه العلاقات بين المملكه وامريكا في
السنين الاخيره يلا لا تخلو من تعطرات الا
انهم لسه محتاجين لبعض من منصور الاقتصاد
قبل السياسه امريكا محتاجه السعوديه لان
المملكه دورها في ضبط اسواق النفطه
العالميه غير قابل للاستقبال والسعوديه
محتاجه امريكا لانها ببساطه مش ممكن
تستغنى عن الدولار تماما في الوقت الحالي
لكن كل السيناريوهات مش هتكون مستبعده على
المدى الطويل لو استمرت التوترات في
العلاقات السعوديه الامريكيه ونجحت جهود
القوه المضاده لامريكا في تقليص هيمنه
الدولار خاصه مع الغضب العالمي اللي
بيتوسع تجاه شنطته لحد كده انا خلصت كلام
عارف ان الحلقه كانت دسمه لكن كل كلمه
فيها كانت مهمه وحكايه البترول كان لازم
تعرفوها وكالعاده في الاخر عندي لكم سؤال
هل ممكن نشوف السعوديه قريب بتبيع كميات
كبيره من الناس طبعا لا الثانيه غير
الدولار والي العملات المرشحه للدور ده
هتتابع اجباتكم كلها في التعليقات وما
تنسوش تشتركوا في القناه زي ما اتفقنا
عجبكم الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير لل للفيديو
ما تنسوش تشوفوا منصه شركه ال محمد ستار
التوجيه لدراسات الجدول هتلاقوا لينك لهم
في وصف الفيديو واهم حاجه تحكم لاصحابكم
وحبايبكم عننا يمكن يستفيدوا
[موسيقى]